trong suy thế hiện lại ngoá quân đội.
Fẹn tích ám ra dục Phà Chià RMP đang lỗi lên như một trong những cộm máy bọc hết việc quả nhất hiện nay.
Phà Chià RMP khai còn gọi là Amrt, Mô đưa vầy cầu, được nhất kế để đặc uống cơ cộng sĩnh hiện đại,
với khả năng linh hoạn và bảo vệ vượt trôi.
Với trường dài, phải vệ bệ mất, châu dọc 2, 3 vệ tà mất, và châu cao 2 vệ bà mất.
Chức xè có thể mang đến người sống người màu hồn bị lãi và bí xí.
Đậu cơ mạnh mẽ, D.E. mời hai của hàng xa đi à.
Giúp xè là không phức, muốn chăm linh năm tí lâu quá, tương đường khoảng 5.5 mạ lực.
Nhờ đó, Phà Chià RMP ở lại tóc đội đoổi đà một trong tí lâu mẽ một dờ trên đường bằng một con số an tượng,
có một cộm máy bọc hết nặn tự ý hả hư bệ mạng rắn.
Với tổng hạ tổng lên tới sống trong tí lâu mẽ Phà Chià RMP,
có khi cơ kia bệ mất gặp dụng của phần chạc, cơ đầu khoảng nhất cảnh hình chính xử,
mạc không cảnh hình dần trải lập đức.
Thả năng vào vệ cao, đến cơ động linh hạc,
hùng cấu hình mô đu đài ra, hợp và truyện rạc á,
ít là sự lượng trọn ràng đầu cho các người dợp dứt giang trên đại.